and you saw their the signature of the
CEO of Ryanair Michael O'Leary here we
can speak to you now and get more on
this mr. O'Leary good afternoon
sarah-jane good afternoon we miss you in
the mornings you can see me in the
afternoons it's a lion for all of us and
now talk to me you're very busy yeah
you're very busy at the moment you're
getting very angry as well the
government's say they are complying with
state aid rules and they've done nothing
wrong but you think this is unfair look
if the government was complying with the
state aid rules they'd published a deal
it's a cover-up it's a cover-up so they
can bail out a couple of billionaires
Richard Branson Delta Airlines and this
venture capital company from America who
claimed to have put in 110 million into
fly B II twelve months ago but are now
only putting in another 30 million
it'll only keep slimey going under March
and then you're back to the same thing
again fly the egos bust again you know
this the reason fly we can't make money
is it can't compete with Ryanair with
easyJet with PA on their main airports
and flying is not some small regional
carrier its principal airports in the a
quarter old website our Edinburgh
Glasgow Dublin London London Heathrow
airline airports where BA
eg jet Ryanair and others whiz and
Norwegian already providing low fare
services so this is a bailout for
billionaires it distorts competition if
you're going to give fly ve a holiday
from the Eco attacks
why aren't you extending a holiday to
all the other airlines so that we can
pass it on to our customers and the
shareholders aren't getting off
scot-free though the government is
asking for further investment from them
one of their shareholders when a flood
shareholders says it's had to put in
nine million pounds to keep the airline
flying and suggested that this trouble
that they've been going through fly B
was down to EU red tape as Stobart group
is part of the connect areas consortium
their own fly B and they say that they
nine million powers said they're not
exactly not putting any more money in
but the but they are I mean they claim
to put in 110 million last year they've
burned away through that Stobart owns a
third of the company so if they're poor
9 million the shareholders are only
talking up another 27 or 30 million the
fighting would go through that but in
three months and then what happens in
March are they back for another bailout
meanwhile they get to keep the APD the
Eco tax which all airlines collect on
behalf of the UK government
well if Sajid Javid wants to give
Branson a bailout of Delta Airlines of
bailouts he should treat the customers
of all the UK airlines not just Ryanair
easyJet be a wiz and others fairly and
that's the reason why they're not
publishing the deals of this subsidy the
billionaire subsidy to fly b e they're
telling us they're complete if they're
complying with the state hayden
competition rules then publish the deal
the cover-up of a billionaire bailout
they might still publish his here and
the UK government does say if it was
good news sergej if it was good and they
sorry if it was good he would've been
published published it before lunch time
okay okay
Sajid Javid to have it nobody's twitter
feed straight away if it was good news
the reason they're covering it up but
the reason they're delaying the release
is they know that it's in breach of
competition and state he drools she know
what I'm gonna go straight to Sajid
Javid Twitter feed after this because if
he's watching that is a challenge laid
down at his door and but let's talk
about the UK government saying that any
relief in ever hats in come on sir Eco
tax who would eventually apply to all
airlines so the government of already
said look we're working this out and
eventually it will apply to all airlines
which is what you're calling for oh but
that's fine but if they're giving that
they say that the condition on which the
shareholders are putting in a measly 30
million into fly b e is the government
is going to give them a two year holiday
on a hundred million aver passenger duty
then they should treat all UK airlines
the same way our customers deserve a
holiday from this unfair eco tax in
exactly the same way that's why these
customers do you can't have it one way
for a billionaire owned airline like fly
b e and not treat ba easyJet Ryanair and
other airlines the same way after all
the reason why remember this is about
the 15th
reorganization our refinancing a fly b
it used to be Jersey European Airways
then it was BA connect
regional this thing goes bankrupt every
year or two and has to be bailed out
again and again and again and the reason
it is is because actually it can't
compete with rail and bus services on
some of the thinner UK regional routes
and it can't compete with Ryanair
easyJet PA and others on the main routes
from Heathrow City Edinburgh Glasgow and
Belfast this is bankrupt airline and we
allege talking to her hat yesterday so
to say that this is a viable company
this company has gone bankrupt three or
four times in the last decade
it's never been viable okay despite the
fact that a bunch of billionaires put a
hundred and ten million into it let's
say okay let's talk about the fact that
businesses are there to make money
what Ryanair if Flybe had collapsed
earlier in the week or is to collapse as
you're predicting later on the year
would Ryanair step in and pick up some
of those routes would you really make
money on a norwich to Jersey routes or
South Hampton to Jersey route would you
step in we would step in on all of them
we easyJet and the other airline's in
exactly the way we stepped in when
Thomas Cook went bankrupt six eight
months ago we were step in and provides
services on all of the main routes we
already fly from those airports in
Manchester Glasgow Edinburgh Belfast
there's other airlines servicing the
Channel Islands they will step in and
pick up more of that business subsidised
airline there so the reason that fly B
keeps losing money is there so few
passengers flying to and from new he and
Exeter most people go by train to new
key and Exeter but what other airlines
step in into that bridge yes they would
we don't know when monarch went bankrupt
we've done it when Thomas Cook has gone
rank up and we'll do it again crane and
if it's like the e goes bankrupt and
it's inevitable it will go bankrupt
again if the shareholders are only
putting in 30 million when the
government is giving them a tax holiday
on over 110 million